All of these are down sides to surveys. We can't always be sure that respondents
are answering truthfully. Even if surveys are anonymous, people don't always
give the truth for some reason. It's probably a psychological thing, and
oftentimes, without realizing it, we give biased answers. Everyone has their own
bias based on where they grew up, the experiences that they went through, their
beliefs and values. When respondents don't understand the questions, we get
what's called response bias. That's why it's very important for those who write
the survey to be very precise in their wording. And finally, some people just
refuse to answer, they don't feel comfortable answering that or they're
incapable of doing so. There might be a certain group of people who don't answer
the questions, and therefore, the data that we get from the survey doesn't
accurately represent them. When certain people refuse to answer, this is called
non-response bias. Remember when we talked about contructs? Surveys are often
used to analyze constructs. And like I told you, I analyzed the construct
effort. As you've seen, there isn't just one definition of a construct, there
are many. Therefore, it's crucial to use as subjective measurements as possible.
Surveys really have to be carefully thought out and worded.